the browns i don't know what to make of
them for the playoffs i don't know what
to make of what i saw yesterday
because it was the browns depleted to a
certain extent by
covet 19 reserve against a steelers jv
team
and it went back and forth it was down
to the wire and it was still in doubt
until the very end when baker mayfield
ran for a first down on third and one
24-22 was the final score let's hear
from baker mayfield on
clinching the first playoff berth for
the cleveland browns
since 2002.
the feeling of walking off the field the
energy in the stadium
you know they're playing cleveland rocks
there's an old pool video going on and i
can look up and see old school
highlights
of you know brian's site bernie kozar
some old schoolers on there it's just
and for it to be that loud with a
limited amount of fans uh it's a special
moment for us
a limited amount of fans can make a ton
of noise they're gonna be going into an
arena
on sunday night with no fans in
pittsburgh and that's going to be a
challenge for both teams in the
postseason though
it should be a lot easier to find your
energy especially with a couple of
division rivals going at it chris but
to to get it done to get in
you know there was some doubt going into
week 17 there was a lot of fear from
brown's fans that when it all
fell apart it was going to be them on
the outside looking in
but you know 18 years browns fans
deserve it and
and the question now is is it just
enough to get back
right is next year the year that that
that you you you advance a round or two
or can they find a way
to beat the steelers in pittsburgh after
getting blown out there earlier this
year it's going to be
an a compelling question as the week
unfolds
but at least for now browns fans just
take a breath and enjoy the fact that
that 18 years is over and you get to
enjoy being back in the playoffs that
feeling of
of anything can happen that's a great
feeling during the the weeks of the
playoffs anything can happen until that
next game starts yeah definitely i mean
i mean how can you not be proud of you
know what kevin stefanski has done
baker mayfield the transformation he had
in his game
throughout the season i mean it's been
it's been fun to watch
i mean cleveland you're on you're on the
right path you really are
everything's going in the right
direction and who knows what happens
next week you're certainly capable of
beating the pittsburgh steelers you know
i got
like a few browns friends who text me
and they're like wow i mean if we
couldn't beat them yesterday more
convincingly how are we going to beat
them when
you know they're back at full strength i
understand that thought
but it's a weird week all together one
hey there is the pressure of
oh man we got to get in the playoffs and
play the steelers on the other hand
are totally free and can just not even
worry about it there is something to
that
you know in a football game to where one
team can go out and just be free and let
it go the other team yeah
their butthole's tight and they're not
they don't want to make a big mistake
sorry
yeah welcome you said poop this morning
i said that hello
welcome to monday morning all right so
now
you get to that and then let alone let
alone
all the damn issues they had to deal
with this week i mean they didn't get
the
full week of practice the meetings were
weird you know you had a they had a
coveted 19
you know conversation every 20 minutes
there in cleveland so it wasn't an easy
week and of course they were missing
players
so it's not apples to apples just
because the steelers weren't
at full strength that this is going to
be a blowout for the steelers this week
i don't buy that
uh i think it'll be a different game and
a different intensity and the browns
will approach it differently too
good to see we're already working on the
highlight reel for 2021 now that we get
started
early or 2020 may as well may as well
get that two minutes and 20 seconds in
the bank as quickly as we can
the the covet issue
was real and yesterday morning
you know i started to see the
perfunctory tweets that all games are on
all games or on i started to poke around
a little bit
the brown steelers game was still kind
of up in the air they were doing morning
testing of brown's players
to make sure they were they were able to
go forward
that they weren't in the midst of an
outbreak they had they had believed all
week that they weren't
but but they still wanted that last all
clear but they got it in they got it
done
and they were depleted and hopefully by
next weekend they won't be depleted you
know one of the risks
of of playing football games and it's
not being on the field it's being on the
sideline it's being in the locker room
that is the most
dangerous day of the week as it relates
to the pandemic and as we see the
numbers continuing to go up and up and
up in the communities and as we see more
and more players catching it away from
the facility
when they gather on sunday when they
gather on game day and yesterday we had
all 32 teams together
including the 14 playoff teams that's
gonna be something to monitor and
you know i know whenever i mention that
like oh you're rooting for it no
i i people need to understand that this
should be on the radar screen
that this is something that's out there
that could undermine
the upcoming super wild card weekend as
the nfl is calling it chris
yeah no i mean definitely it's it's
something i mean i'm i'm watching that
like i'm gonna be watching film on the
on the teams i mean that's that's just
the honest that's part
of the competition this year that is
part of it
plain and simple yeah you got to worry
about game plan and getting ready for
your other opponent you got to worry
about going home
and game planning your life so you don't
get culvert and ruin your damn football
team that that's part of the year
welcome to 2020 football i mean and now
it's the playoffs so
uh it is going to be a big part of it
the steelers have done a phenomenal job
throughout
the steelers needed that rest yesterday
that will be interesting cleveland
though
you know again they were up 24-9 the
steelers got into desperation mode
claypool cleveland did control the game
even though they gave us a worry there
at the end of the football game
and they did do that without denzel ward
and
a bunch of other good players on their
football team in the secondary and all
that so
i'm excited i'm glad cleveland got in
they deserve it it's been tough for
those
and look this isn't the steelers team
that blew out the browns
earlier this year we don't know what to
make of this steelers team they had one
good half of football
against the colts in six weeks
where this team is really going to be
next week
and from the browns perspective they
surely remember the last time they went
to pittsburgh and what happened to them
and if you can get off to a better start
and not fall into that hole early maybe
maybe you have a chance i don't know
this is one that i'm going to spend the
whole week thinking about
especially because my my niece who is a
huge browns fan has already threatened
to disown me if i picked the steelers to
win that game and
and she's she's trying to get me to get
her a ticket to the game it means no
fans
nobody goes to the nobody goes to the
games in pittsburgh i can't get you a
ticket
you know these watches they don't want
to listen to that crap
what but can you still get me a ticket
no there's no fans yeah they have no
fans in pittsburgh
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports